let's take this chance
yeah but obviously like wandering this
knight xc4 was a little bit unnecessary
i must say
now i just remove castling i believe
this dtx4 is never
[Music]
a major issue
and castles castles now some kind of
theory i believe
but it's some weird seal really i don't
think you played b6 c6 with um
with the bishop on before
on the other hand
whatever you do in catalan and black
i mean it can never be too bad
can never be too good either actually
whatever black plays white is slightly
better okay now we get this e4 which uh
gives us a very comfortable position
and then we need to to choose a plan
like it's easier you go e5 one day or
you just
bring all the pieces to the center and
kind of wait for black duct
i normally prefer to wait a little
yeah like you're waiting for something
like
this move exactly and then some lines
can work
for you like knight h4 or something
i don't see why it works exactly to be
honest
i also don't care
so let's play knight h4 he will probably
take on d4
and then knight f5 bishop c5 probably
works for him
a little bit miraculously
i mean work work uh
means that he doesn't lose immediately
obviously white has a decent position
but
black is probably kind of okay
yeah this guy is a bit too strong for me
i don't know what to do let's just take
now it's very dry but still
in my opinion it is slightly better for
white
mostly because bishop on g2 is better
than the one on b7
he plays rook e8 okay
um i guess we take
now we have some knight f5s or something
something should work here
no no okay let's try knight five
he plays queen and fight attacking e3 as
well
can we just play rookie one here
he'll probably play rookie yeah i guess
we think
takes on ad6 he wants to play queen e1
check
knight f1 bishop c6 we take on d5
probably watch this better
yeah so he goes for it
so what is it exactly
bishop c6 i mean it looks really scary
for black like c takes d5 bishop takes
d5
we can take on d5 play some quincy check
knight effect is forced
yeah but he probably holds somehow
which once again looks miracles to me to
be honest
wait this cannot be
is that good for black i think it would
be a bit too much
so c2xd5 bishop takes d5
once the trick is there we can also
start by playing queen check there
knight f8 is still forced there is no
big difference
so we have to take on d5 knight takes d5
then queen e6 is his next move so we
basically have to play quincy
check knight f8
and he's on time was strange
this is really strange
okay let's play some knight five then
also i obviously start to lose
confidence when
for some reason all the lines work for
your opponents and it's uh
and it's not inspiring at all
so now i'm trying to play this in a
humble way like i want to play
knight f5 to 3
and attack d5 like this
but it does not look impressive at all
on the other hand and spree is probably
better than doing nothing
i like this knight on d6 but yeah i mean
i feel too
i failed to come up with a plan
as i can kind of use it now i think f4
is a move
at least i kind of like f4
so he has to keep the queen on the file
not to blunder97 check okay he goes
there
i think we have to use a move here
[Music]
okay let's try this so he's almost
forced to take i believe
or at least it's very logical to take
then 97 check is a straight so he plays
king of eight we go like 93
uh okay let's hope he doesn't
promote after some gtx4 now i think we
have knight d4 and we win a pawn
finally
now like how many things do we need to
trade
okay i think knight takes d5 is not a
mistake
maybe it was a mistake also i don't know
it takes this way
and now once again it's
it's not an easy decision okay let's try
to take with the bishop he'll probably
take and play king is seven
and i think we go king e3 first
now we play b4 i believe
takes takes and then i guess knight c2
king d4
and 93 is what we have to play good
about
and let's hope this is winning
okay
king d3 for now
okay now it's probably reasonable to
play g4
just to secure the e5 score for
e5 square for the king
so what does he want exactly knight is
six we play knight c2
i guess we just go h4 and knight c2
knight sees yeah 94
he has to tank correct
and knight a7 wins nicely right knight
c8
yeah it does
so now i guess we go b5
and we do something simple or we go b6
maybe b6 is the easiest way
i kind of wander this side
so b7 okay let's play g5 first
and king e4
i think i'm yeah i'm about to to mute
play this
but i think we won yeah okay k6 wins
that was tense
all right